الى زاويتنا الاخباريه في مساء العربيه من
مكه ينضم الينا مراسل مساء العربيه هاني
الصفيان هاني اهلا بك معنا مساء الخير
رمضان كريم مجددا نتحدث اليوم عن جهود
وقصص لحفظ سلامه اطفال الحرم وذويهم هناك
صحيح اهلا بك نادين واهلا بك سهام في سابع
يوم من شهر رمضان
ورغم التنظيم وكذلك عمليات الدخول وخروج
المعتمرين وزوار المسجد الحرام في مكه
المكرمه الا ايضا ان هناك جانب اخر وهو
جانب الخدمات المقدمه من رئاسه شون
الحرمين وتحديدا عندما نتحدث عن هذه
النقطه التي ذكرتني وهي امر مهم وهي عمليه
كيف
اذا تاه الطفل في المسجد الحرام كيف
يحصلون ذويه على هذا الطفل هناك مراكز
قبل ان اتكلم عن هذا الامر نحن دخلنا في
عمليه تنظيف الحرم ودخلت في المحيط الذي
تقوم به اداره تنظيف الحرم المسجد الحرام
طبعا ثلاث مرات في اليوم تقوم تقوم اداره
التنظيف بعمليه التنظيف ولكن هذه اللقطه
جاءت سريعا في خلال موضوعنا
طبعا هذا هو معرض رقمي يعرض كسوه الكعبه
وكيفيه استخراج مياه زمزم وكذلك ايضا
التطبيقات الذكيه اللي بامكان المعتمرين
والزوار يستخدمونها طبعا كسوه الكعبه التي
نشاهدها هذه قبل قليل هي عمرها اكثر من 30
سنه وهي من
بعد انشاء مركز كسوه الكعبه الذي امر به
الملك عبد العزيز
الجميله جدا في عمليه كسوه الكعبه وهي في
عمليه حياكه وكسوه الكعبه ولعلها
الاغلى والكل من المعتمرين والزوار يبغون
يشاهدونها بشكل طبيعي كيفيه عمليه صياغه
واحياكه كسوه الكعبه الموجوده وهو هذا احد
منسوبين
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين او ايضا في صناعه كسوه
الكعبه ليقوم بخياطه وحياكه كسوه الكعبه
من الخيوط الذهبيه وكذلك من خامه الحريره
صحيح
عباره عن ايش خيوط بس بشكل سريع الخيوط
عباره عن قطن وسلك فضه مطلم مال ذهب وسلك
فضه خالص
يجوز بسيط فقط للتعريف هذا نموذج تعريفي
لقصه يعني شوف المعتمرين الان سهام ونادين
كيف انه كل واحد يبغى يعمل الخياطه وان
كانه يخيط
ولده ولا ابنه ولا كذلك احد يقرباءه يقوم
بالتقاط الصور يعني ترى المعتمر هنا
والزائر هنا الان هو هي فرصه لهم بانهم يق
ومون بتجربه حياكه كسوه الكعبه والتقاط
الصور الجميله مرحبا فيك
اشوفك متحمس وبداخل في لحظات جميله وسعاده
ما بعد سعاده طبعا اكيد طبعا
ما اعتقد انك كنت اتوقع انك تمسك زي كذا
في هنا المسجد الجديد الحرم الجديد اول
مره اعرف ان في متحف فيه فقلت ازوره
لا حاجه جميله جميله طبعا
يعطيك العافيه
طبعا
مشاعر هنا وما زال الاعداد الكبيره
التوجه الى هذا في هذا القسم تحديدا في
قسم الكعبه طبعا الجزء الاخر والجهه
المقابله الكثير يتعرف على بئر زمزم اللي
ما قد شاهده ولكن هناك فيديو يعرض عمق بئر
زمزم وكيفيه استخراج مياه زمزم الذي يعرض
هنا في هذه الشاشه وكما نشاهد هذا هو
العمق مياه زمزم هناك انابيب ومضخات تقوم
باخراج هذا المياه وهناك ايضا المعتمرين
اللي يشاهدوا زوار المسجد اللي يقومون هذه
الصور ونشاهد احد ايضا موظفين الرئاسه
ليقوم بشرح على عن هذا البئر وبالتاكيد
نحن استمتعنا جدا بهذه الجوله ودائما هناك
مشاريع تنمويه وتطويريه خصوصا في الحرم
المكي ماذا لديك
وقت
انا رايح جاي ما شاء الله للظاهر الياقتي
خفضت في اول شهر رمضان شكرا